chris when i fast forward three months
to the season those three months are
going to be here before we know it i
know go ahead i i'm curious i'm curious
to see now we've still got a pandemic
that's going on by the way that you know
we haven't forgotten about
it's it's still there and there's still
real issues about public health and the
ability to proceed with a season and how
that will unfold and whether or not
people can attend games but on top of
that these social issues where will we
be in three months will there be other
incidents throughout the course of the
summer that that caused these fires to
to burn
fresh again and what will players be
doing
by way of potential protests when yeah
there's gonna be something mean i mean
are we gonna see more anthem protests
again is that gonna create more
divisiveness as we move toward another
presidential election are there gonna be
politicians who who take advantage of
that on both sides um or are they gonna
is the nfl going to come up with a
different way you know i i think that
happened
struggled in 2017 to come up with a
different way for players to make their
voices heard so they don't say well what
platform do i really have during the
three hours that i'm out here on the
field here's the moment where kind of
everything stops during the national
anthem and and this is an opportunity to
express the concerns we have about the
nation that the flag stands for that
it's not perfect it's not what it needs
to be that the american experience
for some
is far different
than the american experience for others
and yeah
and and and that's one and look i've
been meaning to to write about this
arian foster the former nfl rushing
leader
long-time member of the houston texans
he was on pardon my take with our friend
big cat and my internet son pft
commenter
and and he very eloquently explained
that
for americans who have not had
an ideal american experience for
americans who feel oppressed for
americans who feel like america does not
care about them who genuinely feel that
way now it's not for anyone else to say
you shouldn't feel that way the ones who
feel that way the ones who have had an
experience in this country that is less
than what others have had
they look at the flag differently
than the rest of us do
they don't feel the same pride that the
rest of us feel they don't feel the same
passion they feel something different
because their experience in this country
has been
far different
than most of the people who would stand
up and put their hand over their heart
and remove their hat during the national
anthem so that that's and again aaron
foster said it much more eloquently than
i did
but you know it's a different way of
thinking of this problem that not
everyone has had and and we're seeing it
now chris not everyone has had an ideal
american experience and uh and and for
plenty of people the flag isn't as
sacred as it is for others and that's
just the way it is
no it is it's the way i mean i i get it
i do yeah there there's a lot of people
all different colors who feel like you
know they've been cheated by america in
a lot of different ways certainly and i
certainly understand people of color and
african-americans being the angriest
right now as far as the way they've been
treated i mean there's no doubt about it
this is such a huge issue it's it dives
into so many different wormholes and
it's so systemic that it
it's going to take some really smart
people to get to the root of these type
of problems and continue to build this
relationship so white america and black
america can be better moving forward but
like mike back to the other thing too
yeah you know when you talk about aryan
foster or players in the nfl and the
pandemic and what to expect
i mean i i would think there's going to
be some sort of demonstration throughout
the year from players because of this
and i think if the nfl smart they start
thinking of ways right now to do that to
get in front of it to get the players to
rally behind that to where it's
something the nfl does together
collectively you know the players and it
has a strong voice that way instead of
you know kneeling for the anthem which
is for the great cause and we know that
but really bothers people and divided us
in a lot of ways too it brought
attention to the situation but as we
know people took that situation and you
know distracted everybody from the main
purpose and made it about 20 different
other things so that's where i think you
bring up a very real point there and i
think some of the the smart people at
345 park ave need to start thinking
about that right now
and the broader observation is this and
this is as simple as i can possibly make
it when your house needs a new roof
the first step in the process is
realizing your house needs a new roof
and yeah uh
you can't fix the roof until you
acknowledge hey maybe we need a new roof
and i think that the the the ultimate
outcome
to this moment should be that that as
many people as possible recognize
we need
change
a lot of people think the rules fine
though that's the problem right now
that's way too much that's i i know and
uh they've probably already changed the
channel but we're still talking and the
point is
we need to have an overwhelming
sense in this nation that that we need
new roof and uh uh i i that's why
it's important for people to speak out
because it becomes undeniable at that
point and those who
resist the fact that we need a new roof
even as the water drips on their head
they're going to get to the point where
they can no longer ignore and deny that
water is dripping on their
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports